[Musique]
comment faire du barbecue avec une scène
distanciation on n'a plus les barbecues
qu'on avait laissé moi vous savez mais
il n'ya pas que la distanciation qui a
changé les aliments qu'on fait griller
les ustensiles qu'on utilise ont bien
évolué aujourd'hui un banc d'essai de
peps
quelles sont les qualités qu'on
recherche d'une pince avoir vécu
qu'est-ce que ça devrait faire
absolument je cherche la versatilité
parce qu'on mange pas toujours la même
chose sur le barbecue
donc ça prend une pause ce qui va faire
manipuler différents types d'ingrédients
de différentes grosseurs de différentes
formes
ça me prend mâchoire solide avec un bout
qui légèrement pointu qui vaut pouvoir
s'insérer entre les grilles ça facilite
vraiment l'accès à l'aliment ça prend un
mécanisme de quels outils aussi pour
faire qu'elle va s'ouvrir pendant
plusieurs années pour ça ça prend un
retard
idéalement acier inoxydable et d'un
bouquet une dizaine de pain ce qui
représente bien ce qu'on a sur le marché
ou but de l'an 50 à 30 dollars est ce
que le puits déjà au départ une
influence sur la qualité de notre payx
j'en ai trouvé d'excellents à 10 dollars
fonctionne très bien et à 30 dollars
c'est juste qu'il ya plus de petits
gadgets
c'est quoi cet objet là c'est comme la
pince du survival et ici on à la spatule
pas si je vais utiliser la spatule
seulement le bouquin c'est rétractable
et des fautes ça peut sortir
j'imagine que quand c'est chaud et plein
de soleil sur la peau est très pratique
ça fait un beau cadeau pour la fête des
pères mais sinon pour le barbecue comme
tel c'est parce que de plus pratique
même si un décapsuleur donc lui aussi un
couteau sur le côté et un grattoir
nous avons d'abord tester la maniabilité
des pinces avec petites tomates
brochettes et fromage grillé ceni wind
fromage nous avons fait quoi du anomie
j'imagine halloween c'est avec ce type
d'aliments que les modèles avec ma choix
pointus se distinguent vos points tu
prends bien entre les grilles il
tournait très solide mécaniquement chez
le blues ces replis par contre je peux
difficilement me glisser en dessous du
fromage publie c'est le principe c'est
tout donc peu plus frédéric préfère les
mâchoires fines et longues
si on est vraiment très belle manche
soir avec les tanks sont recourbées vers
l'intérieur salle offre une excellente
prise pour brancher sur six questeur
tout ce qui est en partie ce qui est
important surtout c'est que les deux
parties soient le plus parallèle
possible des modèles ou aussi la pointe
se touche tellement que les denrées
cellulaire si la partie ici restent
ouverts donc je peux pas coin syrien
démonstration du pas saint prot facile
pas efficaces dans ce que simon ne ferme
pas très bien la mâchoire qui peuvent
vraiment prise tout le long de l humain
donc seulement dans un poids santé
toujours un risque
c'est un pilote même si chamfort mais
c'est quoi ici ici
admettant qu'on a un petit tacle pour
une personne ça sera une bonne pinte
solide et résistante un drôle d'objet
pour une petite épaisseur les mâchoires
risque de parallèle ça sert quand même
assez bien plus j'ouvre g - ils sont
parallèles plus je suis la misère assez
aisé le produit signé risque
d'hypoglycémie ses limites dans un
exemple peu extrême mais quand même et
je crois que j'ai des fourmillements
choix inspec den broeck l'auzance à des
formules mon choix c'est que l'on
continue de circuler en france mais
légal avec son chef zélé oui
[Musique]
celle là chez hachette rapport celle là
non plus ça non plus notre expert
rapidement éliminé trois passes c'est
l'e3 que je voudrais jamais avoir même
un cadeau
si le modèle le plus court avec manches
iso l'ensemble est confortable et facile
à manipuler
sa mâchoire en silicone n'a pas
convaincu pour une poêle antiadhésive
c'est peut-être pertinent pour le
barbecue une vraiment je voit pas la
pertinence mais trois pins se démarque
du lot vraiment casting napoléon et
cuisine à la cuisine à la mâchoire est
vraiment parfaite le bout et pointu ça
glisse bien entre les grilles et légères
confortables la matière plastique ci est
vraiment agréable la prise est bonne
mais malheureusement je pense que ça va
rester en place très longtemps et elle
vient avec un petit reposiez ici pour
pas salir la surface de travail
nécessaire c'est quand même sympathique
cela fait quand même très beau travail
la pointe de la mâchoire est bonne par
contre la mâchoire et peut-être un petit
peu fragile et il ya encore ici un
plastique souple qui ne durera
probablement pas très longtemps
toutes ces petites pièces détachables
sont autant d'endroits où jus de cuisson
et sauce peuvent se loger rendant
difficile le nettoyage celle que j'aime
le plus mais qui n'est pas parfaite
tout ce qui lui manque a créé ce serait
vraiment d'avoir le goût un peu plus
pointu pour pouvoir glisser entre les
grilles mais c'est un modèle solide
résistant avec des bons ressorts que pas
de petits interstices où les ingrédients
vont s'accumuler
elle fonctionne très bien de la gueule
aussi
[Musique]